Chris
I've been camping for 31 yeah
the apologies that was said on their TV
and I'd set them new face
and then find a neighbor there that
you're going to use the walls law
would you a bit more satisfied
satisfied I would have been satisfied to
a life
this is a 70 year old band
when's anybody gonna talk
crimes like these savings
you still angry with the police yeah I
am definitely definitely I haven't done
the jobs probably
sentence
of everything
I thought I've been through trauma when
I found out it was murdered
okay
Stacy come here let's feel your reaction
um it's not good enough but it'll do it
for now
well there will be more of I think
um for as I say for now we'll just need
to take one step at a time my mom's been
through a lot but that 29 years since
it's not enough for you um it should
never walk me again
how on Earth could he walk free to harm
another child
live without your sister all these years
it must have been hard very
details
um you just have to be strong
be there for my mom now
oh kiss was a talk serious
never asked
Nevada's boo
can I say sorry I'm absolutely
devastated Dr said it's absolutely
devastated
[Music]
which is this is a this is a statement
I'm reading on behalf of Sharon I've
known Sharon since 2006 when I started
to try and help her in her incredible
battle to get Justice for Nikki and I
think we have to really recognize that
if it wasn't for Sharon continuing to
fight all these years
um we wouldn't be here today and she's
she's fought the most incredible battle
under the most awful circumstances what
we want to say is that that this is not
yet the end of her campaign for justice
Sharon demands that northumbria police
are held accountable for the historic
failures there's allowed a 31-year wait
until the right man was convicted of
Nikki's murder the full extent of the
failures
remain unknown
and therefore we are demanding the
inquiry to examine those historic in
that historic investigation which led to
the wrong man being prosecuted and the
police failing to consider alternative
suspects over at least 20 years we are
preparing a complaint to be lodged with
the independent office of police
complaints and exploring a civil claim
for damages against northumbria
um
so the failures stem from a flawed and
corrupt initial investigation into
Nikki's murder which include the
following factors
the original investigation in 1992 was
marred by tunnel vision which focused
only on one suspect George Herron
police sought to bolster their case by
the use of unethical and potentially
unlawful means in order to
secure a charge
in particular they secured a confession
for the man prosecuted by means for
pressure
a key witness Margaret Hodge saw the
murder suspect walking with the little
girl skipping behind him towards the old
Exchange building the scene of the crime
she described a man that did not match
Heron and she and she failed to identify
him on the ID parade the police misrep
misrepresented to Heron the evidence and
the strength of evidence implicating him
in particular in interview they
deliberately misleadingly claimed they
had been positively identified by two
eyewitnesses when he had not and indeed
neither of those Witnesses subsequently
picked him out on identity parades
they subjected her into repetitive and
oppressive questioning in the face of
repeated denials until eventually worn
down heron agrees to a false account of
The Killing
ID parades were held only after Herron
had been interviewed and the two key
Witnesses failed to identify him
Heron's sister Michelle and her
boyfriend Darren Baker provided Alibis
for heron both were arrested for
assisting an offender
Baker was held for four days and under
duress provided in a criminal
incriminating account against Heron
which he subsequently retracted during
cross-examination at trial
when police said following Heron's
acquittal that they were not looking for
anyone else it told Boyd they were not
looking for him
who will have provided him with a sense
of impunity
as the evidence produced recently in the
trial revealed he was a likely suspect
who should have been investigated at the
time in particular he lived very close
to Nikki he knew her because his
girlfriend babysat for her at once
he told the police in door-to-door
inquiries he knew Nikki at the time and
was the last known person to see her
alive
he was familiar with the old Exchange
building having taken a 12 year old boy
there days before
unlike Heron he had previous convictions
including convictions against
girls aged 8 to 10.
although only convicted of one other
serious sexual offense we don't know how
many other crimes Boyd may have got away
with since that time given how many
victims of sexual violence don't have
confidence to report
the police announcement they were not
looking for anyone else also LED Sharon
and her family to believe Herron was the
right suspect who got away with murder
on a legal technicality and that led to
a loss of faith in the justice system
Anger from the local community which was
provoked by this and a failure to secure
a conviction led to some outrageously to
blame Sharon for being a bad mother
which is not
in the years after Heron's conviction
there was no meaningful police
reinvestigation and Sharon was felt her
efforts to push for results were
dismissed her trust in the police has
never been fully restored
eventually she resorted to investigating
suspects herself identifying void under
one of his Suitor names as a likely
suspect
it was only after Sharon went to see the
chief Constable of northumbria police
Steve Ashman in 2017 and begged him to
launch a reinvestigation of the murder
that eventually the new team were
appointed that brought Joy void to
Justice
why was this grieving single mother with
no resources left in this position for
so long
that's why a public inquiry into the
Scandal is
finally we would urge anyone who may
believe they are a victim avoid to come
forward to the police or the Center for
Women's justice so that he can be held
accountable
[Music]
it's a bit like one of a past like game
rooms and gossip
mentioned in the cold
and Nikki was waiting for our mom
but she wasn't because it was made
access to Nikki
go down the house I'll not be long
um
ball juice them words
made your suffering any easier any of
this
I'll never I couldn't understand my
family's in my position as so angry
with the wish was murdered and I've had
to listen to it it's horrendous
um
kind of think that we brilliant our body
is
and I thought life would have meant life
was so poor
I've been let down again by the justice
system
and the police force
um the place for SATs on Nicky's case
now
because somebody forgot to tell us that
they're going to apologize same and then
somebody forgot to tell us that they're
going to use the old justice system
same old thing all the time
simultaneous
well I will because I didn't want this
company with the family
I kind of bring Nikki back I definitely
kind of bring the naked part all the
families are suffering like me and it's
hopefully it's giving them up to a carry
on a fireball